[Music]
book TV is live today from Maryland with
the seventh annual Gaithersburg Book
Festival
you'll hear from authors EJ Dionne
Annette gordon-reed Juan Williams and
first up Kristen green talks about her
book something must be done about Prince
Edward County book TV on c-span - live
from the Gaithersburg Book Festival
[Music]
[Music]
there's four Book Festival my name is
Robert womb a council member here in
Gaithersburg welcome to the seventh
annual Book Festival I'd just say and
thank you for coming out on this this
rainy morning the weather should be
breaking for us soon so let's all cross
our fingers um just the public service
announcement I'd like to put out there
Gaithersburg is a wonderful city and
proudly supports the arts and humanities
we are pleased to bring you this
fabulous event thank you thank our
generous supporters and sponsors for
volunteers when you see them please say
if they hearty thank you
a few announcements for the
consideration of everyone here please
silence all devices if you are tweeting
today you can use the hashtag GBF and we
need your feedback surveys are available
here at the tent and on our website
complete a survey for a chance to win
$100 Visa gift card I'm pleased to be
introducing this morning author Kristen
green she'll be signing books
immediately after the presentation and
copy as ever books are on sale and the
politics in prose tent a great partner
up for us this year a quick word about
buying books even though this is a free
event it does help the Book Festival if
you buy books the more books we sell at
our events the more publishers will are
willing to send their authors here to
the Book Festival purchasing books from
our partner politics and prose does
benefit the local economy it supports
local jobs supports our book festival so
if you enjoy the program and you're in a
position to do so please consider buying
Kristen's book and all the other buffers
books here today so let me introduce
Kristen as I flip my iPhone Kristen
green is an author who grew up in in
farmville Virginia and that's important
because it's important to the story
she graduated from the University of
Mary Washington in Fredericksburg she is
a graduate of the Harvard Kennedy School
of Government she is a journalist she
most recently worked at the Richmond
times-dispatch prior to that she worked
at the Boston Globe in San Diego
union-tribune she currently lives in
Richmond Virginia her works have
appeared in the Atlantic and in NPR she
has a husband Jason and two daughters
who you'll become intimately familiar
with when you read this book so let me
tell you about this wonderful book that
we're presenting here today something
must be done about Prince Edward County
it is a New York Times best seller in
education raised in civil rights
it's a Washington Post notable
nonfiction and for those that want to
support christen it is up for Library of
Virginia People's Choice Award so you
can go to the Library of Virginia
website to vote for Kristen to get this
book not voted as a People's Choice
Award it's an interesting book and it's
an interesting book for me not only
because I'm a lawyer and I love race
relations topics Brown versus Board of
Education is something that I studied in
depth when I was in law school but also
the for those of you that do not know
that Gaithersburg it was voted recently
the most most diverse city in America so
those of us here today who live in
Gaithersburg may not fully appreciate
that race relations were not always as
they've had been and that's what this
book is about Kristen drew up in
Farmville Virginia in Prince Edward
County and for those of you that do not
know this in the wake of the seminal
Supreme Court decision Brown versus
Board of Education which ruled that
segregation of schools and education was
unconstitutional Prince Edward County
was the only county in this country to
close its schools rather than to
segregate to desegregate their schools
and what this book is about is it's an
interesting introspective where Kristen
actually goes back to to look at her own
families involved in her own community's
involvement with this this very
troubling time in our nation's history
so the book will will flip back and
forth between the history which I love
I'm a nonfiction guy but it also talks
about her own experience with that
history and confronting that history
so I encourage you to to to listen to
Kristen here today go to the politics
and prose tents consider purchasing this
book or as I did I went on Amazon and
purchased the book as well so without
further ado I'd like to bring Tristan up
to the stage and let's welcome her hi
everybody thank you so much for that
kind introduction and thank you to
Gaithersburg for having me here today
for this event I'm glad so many of you
came out rain or shine
and I'm just thrilled thrilled to be
here and to be able to share my story
with you I grew up in Prince Edward
County in Virginia which is the only
community in the nation to close at
schools for five years rather than
desegregate it was a story that I didn't
know growing up I only knew little bits
and pieces of what had happened in my
hometown well before I was born and I
became a journalist and was working on
the west coast when I started to develop
in it an interest in learning more about
what had actually happened in my
hometown it took a long time for me to
develop a curiosity about what had
happened because this story wasn't
really talked about where I came from it
was kind of pushed under the rug you
know and and the I think the way that
the story was shared was really
oversimplified so when I became a
journalist and ended up moving to the
west coast
and I became a more curious person I
developed an interest in writing about
people that newspapers don't do a great
job writing about and that's people of
color immigrants people who live in
poverty and it was working on that and
moving to San Diego where I became
friends for the first time where people
of color I met my future husband a
multiracial man and became more engaged
and learning about this history at about
the same time the Washington Post
magazine did a really great exhaustive
piece about what had happened in Prince
Edward it was really the first time that
someone who wasn't connected to me and
Prince Edward was telling a fuller story
of what had happened there and reading
that made me think that that I needed to
learn this full story and then maybe it
would actually be a good book and that
was about ten years ago exactly how long
this kind of project takes to to accept
that you're actually going to do the
project and then take it on let me go
back to the beginning with you and
explain what I learned when I set out to
write about what happened in Prince
Edward in 1951 a 16 year old black girl
walked out of her black high school in
Farmville Virginia to protest the
conditions of that school of course in
1951
schools were segregated so there was a
black high school in a white high school
and she had seen the white high school
that was just down the street and knew
how much better the facilities were at
at the white high school so she led a
protest with her fellow students to walk
out to protest the conditions of that
school and the protest attracted the
attention of the n-double a-c-p in
Richmond Virginia who initially wasn't
interested weren't interested in taking
on her case but they did agree to come
to FarmVille and meet with the students
and their parents there and after seeing
how dedicated these parents and students
were to their cause
they they told them that they would be
willing to take one in their case but it
was on one condition and that condition
was that they would seek integration
rather than equal facilities a year
earlier in 1950 the n-double-a-cp had
changed direction and decided that equal
facilities were never going to be enough
and that they needed to seek
desegregation in schools and in all
facets of public life and so the
students who had this kind of core
committee of students who had planned
for months this walkout actually had to
take a vote on whether they were gonna
agree to go along with what the
n-double-a-cp was asking and according
to students who were there their
decision to go along with this only won
by one vote
she's crazy to me and so this case ended
up becoming one of five cases in Brown
versus Board of Education so Brown is an
umbrella case which I didn't realize
until I started reporting this that that
Prince Edward was the only case of the
five that was student-led and it
produced 75% of the plaintiffs for the
entire brown case so I think that the
bat case emerging from out of out of
print Surry County is kind of what set
the stage for what happened many years
later when the schools were closed I
think white leaders were embarrassed
that that there that this case was filed
against them and they they suggested
that they would build a black high
school for the students they would
replace the high school as had been
requested of them for many years
if only the black students and their
parents would drop this the suit but by
that point the black families wanted to
move forward with a suit and and so
white leaders did go ahead and build
this new high school in 1953 anyway
and as you know the brown decision was
handed down a year later I think that
the white leaders response to the brown
decision had a lot to do with
embarrassment right the bait they were
and they were announced of fear they
were afraid that their community would
be held up as an example to the rest of
the nation and required to desegregate
their schools first as an example
senator Byrd Center Harry Byrd led a
push back to brown v board of education
that came to be known as massive
resistance he believed that the
communities should push back to this
require requirement to desegregate
schools and that if Virginia push back
then the South would get behind them
and and if the South you know refused to
desegregate at schools then the rest of
the country would realize that that they
were never gonna get on board I don't
know if he hoped that the case would be
overturned I'm not sure what his logic
was there but that was his thinking
right and so there were a lot of people
in South Side Virginia where Prince
heard County is located that that
supported that logic and so they in
Prince Edward and other communities
around southern Virginia they formed
these groups called the defenders of
state sovereignty and individual
liberties and the an in Farmville that
group suggested just six months after
the brown hearing the brown decision
that that perhaps closing the schools
something they should do to avoid
desegregation if push came to shove that
they would be willing to do that and I
found in my research that the local
newspaper also suggested this within six
months of the decision
and the pages of this newspaper that
were shaping public opinion said you
know we're gonna refuse to to
desegregate our schools and if we have
to we will close the schools rather than
do so so they put this this idea out
there very early after the brown
decision I think from me working on
research that was a real turning point
to realize that you know a court did not
require Prince Edward to this area at
schools until 1959 it took a court
decision the brown decision ended up
coming on the backs of black families
because of the way the decision was
written and even a follow up decision
didn't make clear how exactly the
segregation was supposed to happen and
on what timeline so black families were
forced to to go to court and ask schools
and school districts to admit their
children right so I think I think in
Prince Edward you know they were out
ahead of the game and and figuring that
they would be forced to be segregated
took this this action by saying it took
the stance that they were gonna close
their schools if they had to and
realizing that they had taken that
position so early right and that they
had had so much time to come up with
better options to come up with ideas
that wouldn't have affected so many
children that for me was a real turning
point a my research at the same time I
also realized that my own grandfather
had been one of those people who was a
founding member and an officer of the
defenders organization in printer County
and that changed a lot for me about how
I approach this book because the book
was no longer you know I could no I
could no longer blame my town for what
had happened but my family was also at
fault and at that point the book became
much more personal as I told you I had I
had met my future husband a multiracial
man and we were planning to have
children and I knew that those children
represented exactly what white leaders
in my town were trying to prevent which
was massagin the mixing of the races
that was their biggest fear that was the
thing that they most wanted to avoid and
when the when it became more of a
personal book then that allowed me to
kind of explore my my grandfather's role
and and how I felt about that and to
look deeper into what had happened in my
hometown so let's jump forward to 1959
when the Court did finally say that
Prince Edward County had to desegregate
at schools
Prince Edward had white leaders had been
prepared for that day right I said that
they they had mentioned this idea of
closing with schools they didn't just
mention it they raised money for that
five-year period to try to start a
private Academy should the need arise
right and so they had been fundraising
or had people promising funds for that
period of time in addition the board of
supervisors there the governing body had
gone to a month-to-month financing model
so that that they could just close the
schools
you know if courts came to them and told
them to desegregated schools they would
be ready to immediately close the
schools so when the courts finally did
did require in 1959 that they
desegregate they were they did is they
had threatened to do and voted not to
fund the schools and by not funding the
schools they shut down all public
education in Prince Edward County you
know the moment that decision was made
these people that had been planning for
years to start a white Academy went
ahead and launched one and they did so
by calling all the white churches in
town the white you know volunteer groups
and civic organizations and asked me if
they could use basements of their
churches and they could use their the
rotary hall in order to hold classes for
the white children their plan was to
have a school up and running it come
fall of 1959 so that white children
would have somewhere to go black
students did not have this opportunity I
mean for them to have started a private
Academy would have gone against what
they were trying to accomplish right and
so and I also think that they didn't
even nobody really knew how long the
schools would be closed even Oliver Hill
the n-double-a-cp attorney from Richmond
couldn't believe that white leaders were
really gonna go through with this right
but they would really close all public
schools they thought this was a threat
and even though you know the doors had
already been locked in the summer of
1959 he was convinced that the schools
would still reopen that fall some
families like families that that were
worried that their kids wouldn't be able
to graduate went ahead and made plans
for their children so and particularly
like the kids who were older you know
years and seniors in high school
everybody realized how important it was
for those kids to get a diploma I mean
if you think about today how important a
high school diploma is at that time for
but child to get a diploma really meant
something and so those families had
worked so hard for that moment that they
that they were you know trying to find
ways that they could that their kids can
graduate and so some students were sent
to live with family members you know
it's just his older sisters or aunts in
the north in particular some students
went and lived at a college in North
Carolina an AME Church related school
that was educating some high school
students agreed to take in about sixty
students from Prince Edward County and
then the black churches also started
these sent training centers in the
basement of their churches where they
were not considered schools and they
they were not taught by you know
official teachers and they were not full
day programs but they were meant to
engage young students so that you know
they could have they could have some
involvement with schooling even though
you know they wouldn't be going to
school that year and so parents of
younger kids did send their their kids
to those training centers
but I have to tell you the vast majority
of black children did not go to school
that year it did not go to school in
subsequent years
nobody had any way of knowing that the
schools would be closed for as long as
they were so children who were old
enough went to work in the fields with
with their parents I mean and and that
extra income I mean most people in
Prince Edward were tobacco farmers and
so the extra income they could get from
extra hands actually meant something to
those families and so it was a positive
in that way but it also meant that when
the schools would reopen many years
later the students were lost they had
been you know they've been working all
those years they they weren't gonna go
back to school and so this generation of
children came to be known as the Lost
Generation because so many of them were
denied an education on the other hand I
just want to point out that that there
were many families who made huge
sacrifices so that their children could
be educated and if that wasn't something
I realized going into this I mean I
really wanted to write this book because
I wanted to tell the stories of those
children who were denied an education
and I wanted to explain what their lives
look like and tell about their various
stories and and there are so many
different trajectories of what their
lives look like after the schools were
closed the one thing I had never
considered was the way that families
were torn apart once that decision was
made that because families really wanted
their children to be educated you know I
write about the ward family in the book
where the two oldest children were about
to graduate you know that I had a rising
senior and a rising junior and so those
children were sent to the AME
Church school in Kerala North Carolina
and then a younger daughter who is
entering high school in ninth grade but
live with her grandparents in a
neighboring County during the week and
then on weekends she would come home to
her her mom and dad but dad was working
second and third jobs in order to
provide the money that these kids needed
to be at Grandma's house and to be at a
school in North Carolina and so Betty
Jean the ninth grader told me it was
like you know it ripped their family
apart they went from being this happy
joyful family where friends were coming
and going all the time you know they
lived right in the heart and a farm
though so it really being like she and
her mom on the weekends at the dinner
table and they would never be a family
like that again except for Christmastime
they never would sleep under the same
roof again like they did then and and I
came to find that that ripping a part of
families really echoed the indignities
of slavery you know and I never I had
never thought going into the the project
about what that would be like to have
your children just you know ripped away
from you so that they could get an
education those stories of the children
and what their lives look like after the
schools closed were some of the most
meaningful parts for me of ever porting
this book there's one student who who
was a really good student and she was
nine years old when the school's closed
and her dad promised her that no matter
what she would get an education and he
was gonna see to that
she and her brother would walk three
miles each way to one of those training
centers her neighborhood school had been
only a mile away so that was much
further and the students the white
students would pass by in the bus and
spit out the window she's walking to
this church training center they did
that for two years and on and off she
would ask she would ask her dad like dad
when are we gonna go to a real school
and he would keep reminding her yeah you
are gonna go to a real school one day
I'm gonna make sure and finally after
two years and there had been no movement
towards reopening the schools he decided
that he had had enough he worked at the
railroad and he had a project in an
adjoining County and some of his white
peers at the railroad helped him to rent
a house in Appomattox County and it was
a rundown house that really wasn't
habitable and they set out to make that
house appear habitable he worked in the
front yard cleaning it up he repaired
broken windows his wife sewed burgundy
curtains to hang in those front windows
but it wasn't till the school year was
about to begin that Dorothy realized
that they weren't actually gonna move to
that house they weren't actually gonna
live in that house instead her dad was
gonna drop her off behind the house each
morning with her brother
and they were to stand behind the house
until they heard the bus coming down
those County roads and it was then and
only then that they were to go through
the back door of the house through the
house out the front door through the
front yard and up the steps of that big
bus and they were never to tell anyone
that they didn't live there because if
they did their education would be at
stake that story just gives me shivers
even today every time I think about you
know what she had to endure to get an
education and what her parents were
willing to sacrifice to make sure that
happened years later that woman Dorothy
Holcomb became a school board member in
Prince Edward County she also worked her
career the state employment office in
Prince Edward County and kids that she
had gone to school with kids she knew
from her neighborhood would come in
seeking unemployment benefits or looking
for jobs and she would have to go to the
other side of her desk and help them
fill out the forms because they were
illiterate
this so this five-year period of not
having schools you know not only
affected those kids and their parents
but it has affected generations of
children in Prince Edward County right
because the illiteracy of those parents
has resulted in in their children not
being as literate as they would have
been otherwise right and I think about
the myriad of other effects of not
having an education that means you you
not not only didn't get to achieve your
dreams in life but the economic
situation that they're in would have
been totally different had they had a
high school diploma had they been able
to go to college right it might have
meant that they could leave that town
and get better jobs it might have meant
they could buy a house so so the impact
on my generation and subsequent
generations has been really significant
and that's part of what I wanted to
explore in this book too I also wanted
to look at what those public schools
look like after they reopened and and
the effect on the town today so that
white Academy that that my grandfather
and other white leaders helped to found
that year in 1959 when the schools are
closed both of my parents attended that
school they later returned to Prince
Harry County and enrolled my brothers
and me in that school and I was a
student there in 1986 when Prince
Herbert Academy is it was then known
finally admitted black students I found
in my research that the only reason it
did so was in order to have its 501c3
nonprofit status restored which have
been taken away for discrimination when
I was interviewing the behalf of the man
who was the headmaster of the school of
the whole
time I was a student there and I said
well you know when you integrated
printer Academy I referred to it as
integrating and he said when we admitted
black students and so that told me a lot
about what the thinking had been for so
many years about about race relations in
that town and and where the Academy
stood in relationship to the public
schools I found in my research that I
mean my belief is that the town would be
better off if there were only the public
school system because such a small
community in rural Virginia is unable to
really fully support to school systems
and without the support of those white
families who for generations have
supported the private schools the public
schools aren't really able to prosper in
the way that they need to and I think
many public leaders still view the
schools as the black schools and
continue to support it as such and so
it's I find that the school system is
underfunded and inadequately supported
by the whole community it's not embraced
as the whole community's public school
system I'm gonna wrap up so that I can
take a few questions real quick way to
tip a few minutes left so if anybody has
a question I'm glad to take it yes ma'am
what got the public schools reopened is
the question the front good question it
actually required another Supreme Court
decision
yeah in order to reopen the schools and
that was 1964 a lot of people really had
hopes that the Kennedy administration
would be able to do something and reopen
them sooner but but they had just as
much trouble doing that as as you know
bike leaders did and building support in
Prince Edward so it did require another
Supreme Court decision and it was a full
five years yes yes sir
there
what do you think there was about the
mindset of those who lived in Farmville
that set that apart from the rest of the
south where they said we will not comply
we will close you know that it was
something about the mindset that that
made them that set them apart from the
rest of the south I think the only thing
I can come up with that makes sense is
that they were really truly embarrassed
about being part of that Supreme Court
decision that of being one of those five
cases and I think that that made them
really want to do something to push back
and and I think that that Senator Byrd
you know had had a huge authority in
that town and was meeting behind the
scenes with with you know prominent
leaders there and so maybe they may have
viewed themselves as a test-case
you know they may have thought like if
we can do this then other communities
can do this I mean and there is evidence
to support some parts of that like the
white leaders that had created that
Academy that I attended created a little
booklet you know explaining how to how
to do this and they suggested to Atlanta
ant in New Orleans that those
communities were also capable of doing
what little TV print xored County had
done and they were traveling around the
country like espousing these views that
if you want to shut down your schools
and start a white Academy here's how you
do it and so you know I I don't know
that they had some particular viewpoint
that was really different than the rest
of the south they just might have had
no more will will to do it because of
the back history there I can take maybe
one more question if anybody has one yes
sir find the students and what kinds of
interviews that you conduct how
difficult was it fine students yeah you
know as I've been a reporter for twenty
years I have never covered a story that
was so rich with with people you can
interview I basically had to stop in
there viewing people at a point when I
reached so many I mean I'd have to give
a little plug for the Moton High School
which was the school that those students
walked out after protest is now an
amazing civil rights museum called the
moat museum if you're ever in Virginia
and have a chance to go Southside
Virginia and go to Prince Roy County I
really encourage you to go to mode
Museum and mode museum is like being a
great partner in that community to help
heal the rifts between blacks and whites
there blacks can come in and tell their
stories of what happened to them why
it's gonna come in and tell their
stories and learn about the history that
they were never taught and when I was
living in in Prince Edward reporting the
book for one summer I went to I went to
every event therefore you know over the
summer and went to weekly events there
for a couple of years and there are so
many students who were affected that I
mean I really could like walk into a
grocery store and probably find you know
five and a single like outing to Walmart
so it was very rich with students who
had lived that experience and from
various perspectives you know it was the
thing that I really realized when I
started interviewing these students was
that there were so many different
perspectives I never thought about what
life might look like for a kid who was
five
when the school is closed right so when
I met someone who'd had that experience
I said oh my gosh I've gotta cast a
wider net at this it was really amazing
to meet someone who did wasn't able to
start their education until they were 10
years old and who was pushed through
school in seven years you know and and
frustrated many teachers and that was a
totally different experience from these
kids who quit school at at 13 or 14
through no fault of their own but
because of the school closures so I did
my best to really try to cast a wide net
and figure out what some of the main
themes of the stories were and I have to
say that narrowing down the stories and
picking just a few to focus on was was
one of the saddest parts of work on this
book cuz I really wanted to include all
their stories I thought they were all so
important and also meaningful and so you
know that was like a great joy and a
great sadness of working on the book was
having them share these stories with me
that many hadn't even shared with their
own family members
thank you so much for having me I really
appreciate it
[Applause]
and that was Kristen green our live
coverage of the gatorsburg Book Festival
continues in a couple of minutes we'll
be right back
tell me